[Musique]
mais alors il va certainement avoir
beaucoup de succès ce film je vois déjà
que le capitaine barril le fameux
capitaine barek et l ex chef du gign le
groupement d'intervention de la
gendarmerie nationale a dit ce matin à
europe 1 que dans le sens de la mission
rambo ça aurait pu être moi
il se compare à hambourg alors
maintenant on va faire une
identification
alors wayne scott il faut le dire et est
un comédien comédiens professionnels
bon alors il ne parle pas français il
parle anglais vous parlait très bien
anglais ce qui n'est pas mon cas
alors est ce que vous pourriez demander
si ce n'est pas frustrant de faire une
carrière de comédien fait de faire une
pause lorsque les comédiens de faire une
carrière parce qu'on ressemble à
quelqu'un de plus connus vous la même
question est dit que dieu a donné son
visage à stallone et lui a donné le sien
et qui a été très bon pour lui au début
de ressembler à salade mais que
maintenant il ressemblera à ce qu'il a
mais ce qu'ils ne disent qu'il ne va pas
être coincé dans ce personnage
maintenant oui les notes des stuck in
death knight
c'est vrai qu'avec des films de
gangsters et des films de méchant il ya
des années burt reynolds elle saisit de
bar le magog brando c'était bon pour lui
ça sera volé ce qui lui aussi fait du
bodybuilding pour s'entretenir les
muscles ça devient ressemble exactement
aux vrais stallone a new build and you
might like stallone ne sont pas le copie
la copier
deux normales aux parfums il connaît
maintenant ils ont une amitié
personnelle il connaît son frère aussi
mais quand même il doit signer des
autographes à la place de ce nom il
signe avec son nom wayne scott voyons
pourrez le regarder chanter lors noble
écouter chanter bien sûr puisque vous
avez il avait apporté un extrait de
cette chanson donc de rambo qui n'est
pas la vraie chanson de rambo mais ce
n'était pas compétent même scott
[Musique]
le temps
oui
ce thème a sur son stand
[Musique]
oh
ou en
[Musique]
oui